you
picture your first cellphone for some
people it was so large it had its own
briefcase for others it was the
notoriously indestructible Nokia brick
phones now look at your current cell
phone besides looking sleeker and more
polished modern phones have some other
neat tricks with a simple okay google or
hey Siri you can tell your phone exactly
what you want it to do and it does it
the point is technology has grown
exponentially in a short amount of time
in 1956 the first commercial hard drive
was the size of two refrigerators and
weighed about a ton and it only had a
capacity of five megabytes and if that
wasn't enough the thing also cost fifty
thousand dollars today you'd be
hard-pressed to find a flash drive that
holds anything less than a gigabyte and
you'd pay maybe five bucks for it in
about 60 years computers have gone from
building scale arrays of towers to being
able to fit in your pocket but what's
more impressive than the scale is just
how smart computers have gotten we
already have artificial intelligence
that can beat the best chess and go
players in the world and we've seen
firsthand the trouble of learning AI can
cause when turned loose on Twitter
according to many experts we're drawing
very close to what's called
technological singularity or just the
singularity for short the singularity is
a hypothetical period in time during
which artificial intelligence begins to
surpass the capabilities of human brain
it's a very hot topic in science fiction
but now software developers engineers
philosophers and other experts are
beginning to give serious thought to the
possibility that we could very well see
sentient machines in our lifetime what
does the advent of such advanced AI mean
for Humanity in our modern society much
of our daily life already depends on
artificial intelligence from sending an
email to making a deposit to flying and
landing airplanes these situations are
all handled by a very specific bits of
AI this specificity is the current
limitation of non-biological
intelligence it can be programmed to do
one thing very well but nothing else in
order to reach the point of singularity
AI would have to be programmed to be
able to improve upon itself any machine
that can learn to correct its own
deficiencies and expand its potential
could quickly snowball and lead to
runaway self improvement cycles and at
some point probably sooner rather than
later human understanding would fail to
keep up the result would be what's
called an artificial superintelligence
and when such a machine inevitably comes
into existence it could have
unfathomable
for Humanity now many thinkers are
careful to point out that it's very
difficult to speculate just how those
consequences will play out since it
would be an entirely new frontier in
technology and would likely impact our
lives in ways we cannot yet comprehend
one of the biggest names in AI
technology
Ray Kurzweil has studied growth trends
in computing for over 50 years and has a
strong track record of accurately
predicting technological breakthroughs
like social media and search engines
kurtzweil suspects that we could see a
computer with human level intelligence
by 2029 he cites current ai's growing
ability to understand the nuances of
language as one key factor for example
in 2011 IBM's Watson took on the two top
jeopardy contestants to see just how
well an artificial intelligence could
perform when presented with questions
involving puns riddles humor and rhymes
which has historically been a major
stumbling block for machines Watson
ended up winning by a landslide but the
most impressive accomplishment was not
the victory itself but how Watson showed
his for lack of a better term thought
process unlike a typical computer Watson
was able to make decisions when it
wasn't sure of the answer for example
when presented with the prompt its
largest airport was named for a world
war ii hero its second largest for a
world war ii battle Watson responded
what is Toronto the answer was incorrect
and Watson knew it and included the
multiple question marks to show its
uncertainty another challenge the AI
faced during the contest was a difficult
prompt that called for a rhyming answer
the clue was a long tiresome speech
delivered by a frothy pie topping to
which Watson correctly responded what is
a meringue harangue perhaps more
significant than this impressive correct
answer was Watson's attempt to figure
out the rhyme that corresponded with the
prompt a boxing term for a hit below the
belt the correct answer was low blow but
curiously Watson responded hwangbang
this was peculiar because nowhere in
Watson's millions and millions of
cataloged words and phrases did
hwangbang appear he invented it because
it seemed like a good solution to the
prompt Watson's ability to grasp the
nuances of language was a huge step
forward in artificial intelligence and
we've seen others since then bots like
Tay tweets have shown how AI can adapt
to and learn from human interaction as
Microsoft found out the hard way when
Tay began to mimic some pretty nasty
conversations then there are groups like
deep mind now owned by Google who
developed alphago the AI that defeated
adult the best go player in the world
the revolutionary thing about this
particular AI is that the ancient
Chinese game we call go is much much
more complicated than something like
chess deep blue the IBM computer that
defeated chess master Garry Kasparov in
1997 was groundbreaking at the time
because until that point no machine had
ever bested a human at chess however
deep blue isn't really all that
impressive due to the limited number of
possible moves in chess it was able to
brute-force its way through the
calculations to pick the best moves go
on the other hand has a staggering
number of possible moves as many as
there are atoms in the entire universe
because of this huge number of
possibilities
alphago had to take a different approach
in contrast to deep blue or Watson
alphago is classified as a general
artificial intelligence meaning it's not
restricted to performing a specific set
of tasks simply put if you provide a
general-purpose AI with a task it's
never encountered before and allow it to
run overnight for example when you check
on it the next morning it will have
mastered the task of course the time
requirement varies with the complexity
of the task but in the case of alphago
deepmind did exactly that with the game
space invaders no experience with the
game then the best in the world the
following morning
these general-purpose AI learned from
their mistakes and successes and build
new and improved versions of themselves
self-improving AI like alphago are the
harbingers of stronger AI to come and
with the rate at which they've improved
even in the last few years many industry
leaders expect it's the exponential
growth within the next decade the
potential next step for AI is what many
people are afraid of including
high-profile scientists and innovators
like Stephen Hawking Bill Gates and Elon
Musk the looming possibility that holds
such appeal in science fiction is the
potential development of what's called
advanced general intelligence or AGI the
distinguishing factor with AGI is that
it's not only able to perform routine
calculations and learn by trial and
error but also exhibit the use of
biological cognitive functions such as
planning using common sense and making
complicated decisions under uncertainty
like any other artificial intelligence
and AGI would begin a software on a
computer as robotic technology improved
we would begin to see tests like the
ones in the 2014 film ex machina this is
where the all too common fear of a robot
uprising comes from in fact Elon Musk is
an investor in google deepmind just to
keep an eye on things while there are a
few high-profile people advocating
others such as Kurzweil maintain that
there's really nothing to fear he
predicts that while yes we will reach a
point at which machines will outpace
humans and intelligence what we should
expect to see first is a sort of
synthesis of man and machine he's not
necessarily talking about cyborgs but
rather advancements in medicine and
nanotechnology that will dramatically
extend and improve human life
kurtzweil isn't alone in thinking this
way Elon Musk is currently working
closely with a nonprofit called open AI
which has the goal of merging humanity
with machines musk suspects that such
measures will protect humanity from
becoming irrelevant in the face of super
intelligent computers it sounds like
science fiction but we've already made
great strides in using technology to
augment people suffering from
Parkinson's disease the next step
according to Kurt Weill is to connect
the human brain directly to the cloud
removing the smart device as a middleman
to the aggregate of human knowledge such
a plan may seem far-fetched but Kurzweil
is quick to point out that predictions
thirty years ago were thought to be
ridiculous but now that they've happened
it seems unthinkable that there was ever
a time without cell phones search
engines and the World Wide Web all of
which he predicted the current goal is
to create a I driven nanobots that could
be implanted in the human brain and
would function just like a wireless card
for your neocortex the region of the
brain associated with intelligence the
higher emotions and creativity in
reycarts wilds words we are going to add
additional levels of abstraction and
create more profound means of expression
so we're going to be more musical we're
going to be funnier we're going to be
sexier and be better at expressing more
loving sentiments so before we can
expect our robot uprising we can
hopefully look forward to disease
fighting nanobots and a direct link to
all human knowledge right from our own
brains not exactly cyborgs more like
humanity 2.0 while there will no doubt
be strong opposition to putting any kind
of technology in our heads
many people eagerly await the day they
can upgrade and be on the cutting edge
of this unparalleled new era of
technology once we've reached that point
then we can start worrying about the
potential legal ethical and societal
ramifications of humanoid robots but
that's a topic for another video as
always I've provided sources and links
for further reading in the description
make sure to subscribe if you haven't
already and leave a comment down below
with your thoughts on the rapid growth
of artificial intelligence you can watch
my previous video by clicking here or
watch them all by clicking here thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video
you